hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his homily number 14 on Paul's letter
to the Ephesians there are a number of
features of language and its connection
with mindset and behavior and
specifically with the emotion of anger
that he views as problematic that John
chrysostom is going to focus on and
there's two verses in particular which
come right after one right after the
other that he is going to discuss one is
let no corrupt speech proceed out of
your mouth which then is followed
immediately by and grieve not the holy
spirit of God and so what's actually
going on there so corrupt speech this
includes a lot of different ways of
talking a number of linguistic modes we
could say right that can be identified
as bad and they're bad in part because
they're connected with anger it's not
exclusively because he also talks about
adultery you know there's types of
speech that Foster that you could say
but here we're mostly interested in the
connection with anger so what what are
the connections well he lists off a
number of different ways of talking that
tend to produce or lead to or intensify
or our expressions of anger and so he
talks about
idle backbiting filthy communication
jesting foolish talking
um and you know he also talks about
lying theft unseasonable conversation a
little bit further down he's going to
say that the mouth this is the cause of
all evil or rather not the mouth but
that they make an evil use of it what
are some of the evil uses that we
haven't already listed off insults
revilings blasphemies incentives to lust
murders adultery steps all have their
origin from this and so you know if we
think about this for just a moment it's
it's tempting to like run through this
list and be yeah a great list but what
are these so idle talk Talking just for
the sake of talking chattering you could
say that can lead to people getting
annoyed why are you talking about this
BS right why are you wasting our time
back biting okay now we've that's
something that can definitely be an
expression of or lead to anger
filthy talking filthy communication
talking about dirty things right which
could be scatological could be sexual
could be all sorts of matters adjusting
now because Justin means joking around
why is that bad well sometimes people
take jokes too far or they're overly
sensitive
foolish talking is also a problem
insults obviously when you're insulting
somebody
unless there's some sort of context
where the insult is taken as being a
joke and everybody's in on the joke
generally if you insult somebody you're
going to make them angry and as we see
so often particularly with the precept
against calling your brother a fool when
we get angry we insult people reviling
saying terrible things about people
complaining about them blasphemies
people blaspheme that is they talk about
religious matters in improper ways very
often when they're angry and that will
make other people angry as well and then
all these incentives that he talked
about before and there's there's one
incentive or train of let's call it
consequences that he brings up as an
example
he says from an insult you're going to
go on to anger that makes sense right
you get insulted you get angry and then
what happens after that from anger to
blows you know you hit somebody smack
somebody and then from blows on to
murder now obviously not everybody goes
the entire extent but this you know this
often does happen so that's corrupt
speech those are ways in which we're not
supposed to be using this faculty of
communication that we've been endowed
with as human beings so how should we
talk to people what would be the
opposite of corrupt speech he talks
about edifying speech or edifying use of
our faculty of speech now what is
edifying it means building somebody up
so instead of tearing them down we're
trying to help them out we're trying to
improve their condition
and he says that you know one way you
can tell that something is edifying is
that the hearer is actually grateful you
know he says by edifying either he means
this that he who hears you may be
grateful to you and he uses an example
here a brother has committed fornication
how are you going to talk to them about
this because you shouldn't just remain
completely silent be like hey man
whatever you do is is cool by me but if
somebody's screwing up you should talk
to them about that so that's that's one
way of thinking about it and then
another we could say Criterion or
measure is that the hearers are as he
says filled with grace and here you
might be like well wait a second from uh
Christian theological perspective human
beings don't fill each other with Grace
that's what God does right it's this
Supernatural activity well yes but human
beings within we could call about the
mainstream of theological Christian
theological
discussion and interpretation really
from early on all the way up to you know
and and through the Protestant
Reformation human beings function within
the economy of Grace to help other
people receive Grace this is talked
about by so many commentators that I
probably don't need to stress it so
we've got two criteria that are being
given for edifying speech and then we've
got sort of a description about how this
works so let's come back to the brother
who has committed fornication
how should you talk to them so
chrysostom says don't make a display of
the offense nor Revel in it you're not
going to be doing good to the person
that hears you rather it's likely you're
going to hurt him by giving them a
stimulus so you shouldn't be doing one
of two things first of all don't uh
Revel in it don't be like engaging what
we call locker room talk ooh you uh
committed fornication I mean you've had
sex outside of marriage was it good did
you have a fun time what kind of stuff
did you do what positions how long did
it go you don't have to do that that is
the opposite of helpful you're just like
getting the person back into their
memories of that but you also don't need
to like you know rub their nose in the
dirt so to speak and be like oh you
dirty dirty Pig you you awful person
you've committed fornication God is
gonna hate you that's that's not helpful
either right how should you actually be
talking about them this this man so he
says advise this person what to do and
you're conferring Adam a great
obligation
and then he talks about a few other
things that are connected with this
discipline him how to keep silence teach
him to revile no person and you've
taught him his best lesson you'll have
conferred on him the highest obligation
discourse with him on what on Contrition
feeling sorry for what they did on piety
on almsgiving all these things will
soften his soul
for all these things he will own his
obligation whereas by exciting his
laughter or filthy communication you're
instead going to be inflaming him right
don't applaud the wickedness you're
going to overturn and ruin him
and so you know this is some some useful
uh advice I think how should we deal
with people who are airing how should we
talk to ourselves also when we're
screwing up we might think about that
coming uh to the discussion of grieve
not the Holy Spirit what does this mean
well
it's interesting because he begins by
saying that
um
the person who rejects rejects not man
but God this is in Thessalonians and he
says so also here if you utter a
reproachful word if you strike your
brother you're not striking him you're
grieving the Holy Spirit obviously you
are of course striking them and saying
bad things to them but you're ticking
off you're grieving the holy spirit of
God why because God wants us not to do
that sort of thing to each other God
wants us to love each other and to be
connected right and so
um you know he says we need to think
about
how we use our faculty of speech and
here he brings up this conception of a
spiritual mouth it's kind of funny by
the way because John chrysostom right
golden mouth right is bringing up a
mouth and when we think of a spiritual
mouth it's not like we have a second
mouth or something like that it's the
spiritual use of what we have been
endowed with you could say physically
and uh mentally and all of that so he
says a spiritual mouth never utters a
thing of the kind say not it is nothing
if I do utter an unseemly word if I do
insult such a one for this very reason
it's a great evil because it seems to be
nothing things which seem to be nothing
are easily thought of lightly and those
which are thought of lightly go on
increasing and those which go on
increasing eventually become incurable
they become bad habits what we call
vices all of these sorts of you know
corrupt speech if we engage in them over
and over again and we're like ah not a
big deal then sooner or later they
become part of our our character right
so we shouldn't be using our spiritual
mouth for as he says cruelty right we we
should be using it for good things he
says uh disgrace it not then after
receiving it from Pure loving kindness
that or philanthropy love of human
beings that is from God by showing
cruelty towards your brethren do you
call god father and yet attack revile
your fellow human being well these are
not the works of the Son of God these
are very far from him and he says we can
think of Christ's example what did
Christ do I mean Christ did go around
and criticize people right he uh
criticized the Sadducees and the
Pharisees and he tells people hey man
you're screwing up you know Peter uh you
screwed up get behind me Satan right he
meets a a woman who's had a whole bunch
of husbands and you know or has actually
sleeping with a whole bunch of men and
he's like none of them are your husband
stop doing that right but he's doing it
in a way that is not attacking the
people at the core of who they are
there's always the possibility of doing
better and he says the work of the Son
of God was to forgive his enemies
to pray for those who crucified him to
shut his shed his blood for those who
hated him these are the works worthy of
the Son of God what is he doing to make
enemies The Ungrateful the dishonest The
Reckless the treacherous to make these
people Brothers Brethren and heirs to to
connect them back up with God so that is
one powerful example of how we could be
using our mouth correctly he's also got
this very interesting uh metaphor of a
spiritual vessel a royal vessel as the
translation goes here Suppose there were
a royal vessel and that always full of
Royal dainties that were Royal dainties
it could be like you know candies or it
could be whatever it is that you really
like so you've got a vessel namely a
holding thing and then it's full of nice
stuff so imagine you walk into
somebody's office and they're into you
know jelly beans right and they've got
this Crystal bowl and it's full of the
best jelly beans or Gummy Bears or
whatever it is that you're into right
and you like reach in there and you take
one Mmm Yeah that's tasty now imagine
that it's full of crap literally full of
dung or poop
so you're taking this wonderful vessel
and you're filling it up with turns
um is that you know is that any good he
says would you ever Venture again after
it had been filled up with dung to store
it away with the other vessels set apart
for other uses surely not and then he
says now railing is like this reviling
is like this you're using your mouth
this precious vessel for doing all sorts
of corrupt odd unclean bad aggressive
things perhaps motivated by anger
perhaps motivated by other things and so
that's you know a bad idea right and he
gives some examples of this coming from
you know uh Parables what if a servant
even with us beats his fellow servant or
assaults him even though we do it justly
yet we once rebuke him and he and deemed
the act and outrage right if you if you
think about that then aren't you ashamed
when you're thinking about like you know
praying to God about all the other crap
that's in and coming out of your mouth
and so one of the other things that he
talks about here
is disciplining our mouth to silence now
does that mean we have to be quiet all
of the time no
um we should be prudent in what we're
saying he says there's a great Advantage
from this and there's also a great
Mischief from ill language
um let's you know let us devour
ourselves alive if ever a vexatious word
slip out of our mouth let us entreat God
let us entreat him whom we have reviled
let us not think it beneath ourselves to
do so so obviously we are going to keep
communicating
but we're going to shut up when it comes
to doing the things with our models that
we shouldn't be doing very often
motivated by anger or leading to anger
and we're going to use our mouths our
you know spiritual mouth for its right
purpose which is to edify to rebuild to
restore to lead back to the right track
to
reconcile and to fortify good
relationships